[Music]
okay 1835
ali rio
helves from columbia
okay e4
so let's play
let's play traditional let's play e5
okay knight c3 so this could be a lot of
different things our move is knight f6
this could be the vienna
okay no it's knight of three it's the
four nights knight c6
and the four night scotch so this is
interesting we're actually facing
a four night scotch which uh is is quite
rare we're usually on the other end of
it
now i'll show you guys a line which is a
little bit less uh well known than the
main line but which i think is
uh no worse this is actually what i play
in my over the board games and my in my
actual blitz games so as as you know we
play takes d4 here and who can remind me
what the main move is after knight takes
d4 so what is the most popular move in
this position the move that is
recommended
in most books
in most videos it's the move bishop f8
to b4 yeah so the development of the
bishop to b4 and that leads to the main
line with knight takes c6 and then
bishop d3 etc
but the move that i like is bishop c5
which might strike you as even more
natural but it is not the main move
it's it's the second most popular move
and it's very reputable but it's not
actually
as popular as bishop before and some
people don't know it quite as well
and i like to choose my repertoire and
build it around these moves that are not
sidelines but not quite the most popular
move to make it a little bit less likely
that my opponent knows what to do so
knight takes c6
obviously not dc which would allow the
queen trade and would get our king
deprived of castling rights and ruin our
structure we play bc
in these positions
and bishop g5
so bishop g5 is one of many possible
moves nothing particularly special about
it
one thing to understand is that
white isn't really threatening e5 at
this point for many reasons
one of which is that
if we castle which is what we're gonna
do
e5 can be met with rook f8 to e8 right
and we pin the pawn and because white is
so underdeveloped there's no way that
he's gonna keep this pawn alive and then
on the next move we can play d6
in order to prevent e5 once and for all
but as long as y does not develop the
bishop you don't need to worry about e5
being a thing
okay now e5 is kind of a thing
so do we go h6 a lot of people wonder
like do we throw this in how do i know
now in many cases it doesn't really
matter in this particular instance i
like throwing an h6 and there is a
specific reason for that and the reason
for that is that after we go d6 and then
we go rookie 8 we have potentially the
possibility of winning
the e4 pawn by playing g5 right
so i kind of like that concept
okay so rookie 8 is good we can also go
queen e7 and try to get the queen to the
center with the queen e5
many ways of playing such a position
but i like traditional move rook eight
let's play it old school
this is like very old school bishop f3
okay so
at this point we already have a very
interesting possibility of going g5
and then meeting bishop g3 with g4
and after bishop e2 actually taking that
pawn on e4 which is quite risky
but also very very interesting and one
thing that i want to prove to you as we
hit 1800 is that on the one hand king
safety is the most important phenomenon
and the most important factor in any
position on the other hand
you shouldn't always worry all that much
about pushing pawns in front of your own
king and what i will try to show you
here hopefully i will get away with this
is that
just because you've pushed pawns in
front of your king doesn't mean
that your opponent is automatically
going to checkmate you so let's go
through this line g4
bishop b2 and we're going to snag the
pawn on e4
and i'm going to try to prove to you
that our king is essentially in no
danger whoa e5 that is not a move i
expected and i don't think it's a
particularly good move it might avoid
material losses but i think it gives us
a very nice end game potentially so what
should we do should we take on e5 or
should we take the bishop let's not get
disoriented
all right don't get disoriented what
does e5 actually accomplish well it
opens the bishop's diagonal and
threatens bishop takes c6
so we should definitely take the bishop
okay now
um the brazen move would be f takes g2
but leaving this pawn on f6
is perhaps a little bit too brazen even
for me i wouldn't want to leave the spot
on f6 because it creates the potential
for a lobster pincer mate
um
let's play it safe
and let's play queen takes f6 let's get
rid of that pawn get a good position
let's not bother with bs queen takes f3
and this is what i meant when i said
we're going to get a good end game
because what we're going to do now
is we're going to trade queens
absolutely
the white's king side pawn structure is
ruined now you could say that our queen
side pawn structure is ruined but our
queen side pawn structures is quite
compact
whereas the king's side structure is
just terrible
now we need to develop actively right we
need to figure out where white wants to
put put his pieces and we need to
develop accordingly i think a lot of you
are tempted by bishop h3 but that's
actually not
a great move that's a step in the wrong
direction because it allows the rook to
get active rook f1 which is something
that white wants to do anyway and if you
look very carefully at what y wants to
do you'll notice that the c3 knight has
a very nice square on e4
why is that a nice squirrel because it's
centralized it's anchored by a pawn and
the knight threatens to jump into f6 so
the way that we want to develop to stop
that is by going bishop f5 yeah bishop
f5 stops knight e4
d5 would hang c7 i didn't want to give
up a pawn
in general d5 would be preferable but in
this case we can develop
while preventing 94 and also
while attacking ct okay our opponent
does it anyway just giving up a pawn
obviously we will take it and now we
have control over the e-file as well
so
we don't want to trade on e1 i think
some people
would make you know the mistake of
thinking oh i can simplify right but but
simplify on your own terms
and how do you set up your own terms f5
is a tempting move that's f5 is possible
but i don't see the point of playing f5
in light of the fact that we can double
rooks on e8 and keep control of the
e-file
thank you coaster card okay so
this is an interesting moment right we
can trade up all the rooks we can trade
four pair four rooks
is that bishop end game winning
well probably it is right bishop end
games up upon are often winning but
they're not
comparable to pawn end games so
i've i've encountered bishop end games
like that which are not
easily winning
so i would find a middle ground here and
i would say okay if white really wants
to trade rooks we can let him do it but
while white is busy trading rooks and
going rookie one we are going to improve
our position now in the context of an
endgame what does it mean to improve
your position well it basically means
bringing your king up that's the top
priority let's go king g7 and get this
king up into the center f5 or maybe e6
d5
and if our opponent makes it draw in
that bishop end game congratulations
right but at least we're going to make
improving moves while our opponent is
busy trading rooks
hopefully that logic makes sense
okay so now we're going to trade we have
no i mean f5 is possible but then y can
go f3
i don't see the point in dilly dallying
any further
okay so now this is a very instructive
moment actually because it's very easy
to miss an opportunity to play a good
move here
if you look carefully at the bishop
right
white wants to play the move c2 c3
why what is that going to accomplish
what that's going to accomplish is it's
going to keep the bishop essentially
confined on this diagonal
why because well the bishop can't really
escape
and you can't really go d5 and bishop d6
because c7 is going to hang so you
currently have an opportunity to get
this bishop into the center but this
opportunity may never occur again
because white wants to play c3 now maybe
our opponent doesn't play c3 but we
shouldn't operate under that assumption
i like the move bishop c5 to d4 and if
c3 happens we can reroute the bishop
into the center with bishop e5
and hopefully that makes more sense
now you might say wait a minute after
bishop e5 there doesn't white have the
move f4 and he does but f4 is actually
more harmful than it is good because it
pushes the pawn out to a dark square
okay king e2 wow now this allows us to
transition into a pawn end game and most
fun end games up upon are going to be
winning this one i think is probably no
exception i mean it's
i wouldn't be 100 sure that it's winning
but i i'm sort of 90 sure that it's
winning
yeah we're just gonna trade i mean i i'm
my intuition is telling me that despite
despite the fact that our pawn structure
is kind of ruined here
nonetheless
i like i like our chances here now our
top priority right now is obviously to
get our king into the center that is and
this is very fitting because i'm
currently doing a series on pawn on him
so i better prove my metal
okay
so now
we need to figure out first and foremost
what the potential for us is to create
past pawns
and
what i see is that we have the potential
of going c5 followed by d5
and d4 so we don't have to worry about
white's king heading toward the king
side right we don't have to worry about
that because the moment that white goes
king g4
we will play c5 and we will initiate the
process of creating a past pawn
okay there we go we're going to go c5
now
in the video i have this rule about
pushing the perspective password which
is the d-pad this is a slight exception
to the rule because it's a very unusual
structure
very unusual structure if you go d5 you
will be subject to a deep freeze black
white is going to go b4 and then you're
not going to be able to go c5 normally
these pawns aren't doubled so that's not
a problem
so now we go d5 and there isn't even a
pawn race
to speak of the game is over we're just
gonna go d4
the white has gone completely wrong off
the rails here and our opponent didn't
stop to ask himself
how black can create past bonds he just
sort of assumed that we can't do it
and and so i don't think he put any
amount of thought into this idea
okay we can just go king e4 it doesn't
really matter we're obviously going to
win the pawn race
there really isn't even a pawn race by
the time white wins f7 we're going to be
promoting our pawn
and if you want to be super clinical
about it after king g7 you can even play
the move f5 like you can if you want not
even give up
not even give up a single pawn
and if white goes g4 then you play f
takes g4 and the f1 isn't even going
anywhere then we have like trousers but
both pawns are unstoppable
f5 is is clinical now we go d3
and g4 we can take it
and the hilarious thing is after f5 we
can push either of our passengers right
we can play g3
because we promote check or
the simpler option is to go d2 d1 queen
and i know some beginner players
struggle with these types of situations
there is a
more laborious way of winning this then
there's an easier way of winning this
particular position right the easy way
is to basically say okay i'm going to
give up my queen for the pawn and then
i'm going to promote my other pawn
but if you want to be super clinical you
need to use the technique
that is uh essentially imagine that
there was nothing left on the board
except a queen in this pawn then the
position would be drawn because of
stalemate concepts here you don't have
to worry about stalemate concepts so you
actually don't have to give up your
queen for the pawn you can use your
queen to essentially shepherd the white
king
off of the pawn
so a good solid kind of
simple positional game
and we're winning more of these as we
hit you know 1800
so yeah bishop c5 is a good is a good
line if you're if you're an e5 flare
knight c knight takes c6 is one of many
possibilities bishop e3 being another
possibility
bishop e3 is another possibility
um and i believe the most popular line
there is also
knight f5 there's also knight of five
here so this is a theoretical line you
can you can do some research yourself
um okay so take stakes bishop g5 is
again one of many possible
variations
bishop d3 is the main line bishop d3 is
the most popular move
and then the line goes d6
and this is the main difference between
putting the bishop on c5 and and putting
it on b4
like when you put the bishop on b4
you're basically not i mean d6 is a move
here but d5 is what almost everybody
plays
when you put the bishop on c5 on the
other hand you're going for d6 so in any
case bishop g5 is a move
so we castle bishop e2 we throw in h6
and i think bishop b2 is already
inaccurate
i think our opponent didn't realize that
the e4 pawn constitutes a a pretty
serious weakness here
and i think that
had he known that he would have played
bishop d3 which sort of
supports the pawn
so we go h6 we go rookie we go d6 we go
rookie a we make all the typical moves
and bishop f3
is probably a mistake assuming
that this is objectively sound
and i think it is objectively sound
what about h6
e5
well h6e5 just loses the pawn takes
takes takes
we just went upon like at the end of the
day
85 is never dangerous
so
how should white have played here i
don't actually know i mean at this point
white is a very hard time keeping this
pawn
what is a very hard time keeping this
one maybe a move like king h1 would be
best
you know this is a grand master move
your bishop d3 i mean king h1 is
interesting because after g5 bishop g394
the idea
is to win back the pawn with bishop f3
although here there's rook d4
attacking the queen
so this all looks pretty nasty min
suggest bishop d3 kind of
apologizing for
playing bishop e2 initially and this is
actually transposed into a line that has
10 games in the database
bishop b4 f4 i think this might even be
sevi and caruana from the us
championship so bishop d3 was best
um
of course
lol back to pushing all the pawns in
front of my king after this game so e5
is sort of sort of
uh
makes our job easy
bishop e2 we play knight takes d4 yeah
and like this position is a classic
situation where yeah we pushed all these
pawns in front of our king but how is
white actually going to to to exploit
that
right i ask this question so often in
lessons when i have like a student says
oh i don't like this because of x y and
z
um
okay but how is white going to attack
like give me a move right
now you might say okay bishop d3
big whoop you just come back with your
rook
then you can move your queen into g5 and
if anything black can be the one to
attack on the king's side you're going
to go h5 h4 and this bishop is going to
be in trouble the white bishop belongs
on d3 like that is our one of our
opponent's main mistakes is not to put
it there
um does that make sense like queen d2
you can even go queen g5 here
okay i guess i guess bishop f4 is quite
annoying but
no i would absolutely play it over the
board queen f6 i would absolutely play
it over the word that's the point
i i mean i was a little bit skeptical
initially but now that i have myself
played these moves on the board
um i've realized that it's totally fine
for black now white should probably play
bishop takes g4
but what i was thinking about doing here
is either going queen g5 immediately or
snapping off this bishop first get rid
of the dark squared bishop and then get
the queen to g5
and black has a very dynamic position i
mean you're threatening queen takes g3
you've got a nice bishop
black has absolutely no problems here
despite having a bad pawn structure
and pod structure is the most visually
apparent aspect of the position but not
necessarily the most important one
um
so anyways our opponent didn't opt for
that and instead opted for e5
and we had this big trade queen f3 queen
f3 gf so bishop f5 very important move
very important move
uh stopping knight e4 our opponent
played in any way giving up a pawn
just sort of
tilting here rook a8 so we double on the
on the e file we got our king up
and i just want to get to the get to the
pawn again this is a very important move
right this is the kind of move that
you know is hard to play unless you're
very experienced in the end game
because it can be hard to to tell even
why it's bad that your bishop is sort of
trapped here
but the reason it's bad is because
it's like what are you gonna do with
this bishop it has to remain between b6
and c5 for basically the rest of the
game
uh and it's very important for the
bishop to have more mobility
so bishop d4 c3 bishop b5
was a b3 a bad way to save the b2b no b3
is possible but then we get our king up
to f6 and then we get it up to f5
and then we play bishop e5 so this is
all pretty bad for white
and if white had gone f4 we simply
dropped back to f6
yeah maybe you can get the king to d7
there but it's it's very cumbersome
and now this is winning for black
because this pawn is an incredible
weakness i mean it's incredibly weak
and and we can attack it in a variety of
ways by getting the bishop to either d6
now you can play d5 the white bishop is
no longer making contact with the c7
pawn
and you're just going to get your bishop
to e6 and you're going to grind wide
down here
you can create a pass upon late later
this is definitely winning
so our opponent traded bishops or
allowed the bishops to get traded
how could white have made it dry i don't
think white could have made it draw
i think this is a win for black but we
will check with the engine i'm not
positive
but i i i think this is a win for black
now why should have kept the king in the
center and white's only chance is to
keep the king
in the center and try to prevent black
from creating a passer
but ultimately i don't even think that
you can help prevent black from making a
passer
and if white plays that f4 check and th
this gets into some very instructive
upon end game concepts which i'll delve
into into later videos but f4 for
example is a big mistake
and a lot of people would play this
thinking oh i'm just going to push
black's king away with g4 but
again the deep free well not really the
deep freeze but freezing the g4 pawn and
g3 is a weakness
people don't think of end games as
like you don't think of weaknesses in
pawn end games but that's a thing like
you can have a big weakness in a pawn
end game and now g3 is a very serious
weakness which can tie down white's king
uh did you consider play bishop d4
before you trade the queens
let me see
let me rewind
yeah bishop d4 is fine
but why give up the pawn like why why
allow queen takes c6 right and also
i didn't want to pass up the opportunity
to
for for white of course to ruin white's
pawn structure no the pawn end game is
losing for white i'm positive
the more i look at this the more
positive i am that white is losing just
because
um no matter what what y does black has
this plan of pushing c5 and d5 and d4
and creating a passer well you can't
really
you can't zoom along this because like
black has a series of moves that
improves his position
right the zookasong happens when you
don't have any moves available that
improve your position here black has a
clear plan
i will check the engine but i can almost
i can bet you a silver dollar that this
pawn end game is winning for black
so g5 g4 is best you can see that the
engine oh bishop f3 actually is best
what's up mr llama what if white plays
b4
okay we'll talk about that in a second
so e5 is bad yeah bishop b2 is best and
actually what we talked about bishop to
hg4 and the position is about equal
the position is about equal and you can
see queen g5 is one of the moves
so
oh so this is what we analyzed sorry
sorry so why played e5 this is bad
yeah so fg is the computer move here
i've i knew it was possible to play fg
but i didn't want to to risk it right
the computer wants us to play like this
and allow the f6 pawn to be defended and
why why be crazy right i mean we just
take f6 we have a great position
and minus two i mean white's position
sucks
so we played really well here
and bishop d4 is good but king f6 also
is possible
so the engine eval
is only like -1 there's a discrepancy
between the evol in the game review and
in the
the actual analysis
so let's see
no it's winning
it's winning
um
the engine move is b4
which mr lama suggested which is best
that deep freezes the pawns by the way
classic example of a deep freeze but
after king f5
no it's winning f3 or what a king f3 h5
you're going to grind white down one way
or another so i would invite you guys to
actually analyze this on your own
to use an engine and and set up this end
game
in a chest.com analysis board
and figure out why black is winning
now this is going to be the subject of a
later video basically the reason that
black is winning here is because the
black king is is going to make inroads
by force
white is gonna run out of pawn moves
like c5 you can see bc
dc a5 white is gonna run out of pawn
moves
and eventually the king's gonna have to
go to the side and then black's king
starts making inroads
and this is a classic idea
and the the the king is going to make
its way to f3 and then black is going to
create a passer by pushing this f pawn
off to f4
destroying the g3 pawn and then you're
going to have an outside passer so
there is
a lot to unpack in the sand game but i'm
really tired guys i'm gonna call it a
night
so you're welcome to do some more
analysis on your own
i'll give hannah a raid i'll see you
guys later
and thanks for hanging out everybody
i'll see you tomorrow bye
[Music]